[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 tout de suite les titres de ce
mardi 12 septembre la mobilisation
sociale contre la réforme du code du
travail
un cortège de manifestants a défilé cet
après midi à paris et les neuf l'union
locale de la cgt 78 ans ont participé
il avait pris le départ depuis le
département plus tôt dans la journée
il est d'une violence jamais enregistrée
dans la zone lourds où l'ouragan irna a
dévasté les antilles françaises ainsi
que toutes les caraïbes et des
opérations de sauvetage et de solidarité
se sont organisés du côté des yvelines
nous en parlons avec nos invités le
capitaine sébastien avenel et jean luc
hislop président de l'union locale de la
croix rouge de saint quentin en yvelines
enfin dans un an c'est la ryder cup qui
déroulera du 28 septembre au du 28 au 30
septembre 2018 au golf national
la coupe du monde de golf est très
attendu un compte à rebours vient d'être
lancée à voisins le bretonneux et pour
débuter ce journal un droit de réponse
celui du département des hauts-de-seine
qui avec le département des yvelines
dont il ya un projet de fusion
il indique que ce projet n'a pas encore
été rejetée par l'état
une décision officielle ne doit
intervenir qu'à la fin de l'année
il ne s'agit pour l'instant que deux
rumeurs émanant de certains ministères
contrairement à ce que laissait penser
notre reportage hier
cela fait un siècle que paris attend son
heure demain à lima au pérou le comité
international olympique officialisera sa
décision sans changement de dernière
minute léger ou 2024 devrait être
attribué à la capitale et les derniers
jeux olympiques d'été s'y étaient
déroulés en 1924
s'en est suivi plusieurs échecs pour les
candidatures en 1992 2008 et 2012
annonce officielle demain aux alentours
de 20 heures
et pour cette grande journée de demain
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organise des
animations dès 17h en présence de
nombreux sportifs français comme
l'équipe de france de cyclisme sur piste
est l'événement de demain se prépare
d'ailleurs dit
aujourd'hui au vélodrome nationale les
installations ont débuté dans l'enceinte
50 rhinoise qui s'apprête à recevoir
beaucoup de monde pas moins de 800
enfants notamment des écoles du
territoire propos recueillis par michael
et demi d'euros
là on est en plein montage du site on
installe certains ateliers on a le
terrain de foot qui est déjà mis en
place
on est en train de mettre le parcours de
golf
on finalise la signalétique enfin voilà
on a pas mal de personnes mobilisées
pour faire en sorte que demain tout soit
fin prêt pour accueillir les scolaires
aux journées et après le grand public à
partir de 17h je vous le disais en titre
journée a marqué par la mobilisation
sociale contre la réforme du code du
travail à l'appel de la cgt est défilé
dans les grandes villes de france comme
à paris et les militants de la cgt 78
ont pris la route de la capitale en
milieu de journée une soixantaine de
personnes notamment depuis de trappes
nicolas kirillovitch étaient sur place
le rendez vous était donné sur un
parking dans une ambiance calme à
l'heure du déjeuner près d'une
soixantaine de personnes ont répondu
présent au départ organisé à trappes par
la cgt 78 et l'organisation au point
retraités salariés ou chômeurs soit
faire passer leur message tenir bon
malgré la détermination répétées du
gouvernement à réformer le code du
travail par ordonnance la rue fera
reculer un jour ou l'autre même si avec
la loi comme rit ou on a eu beaucoup de
manifestations n'a pas fait reculer mais
il le paiera cher quand même un moment
ou un autre et la cgt a déjà prévenu une
nouvelle journée de manifestations est
prévue le 21 septembre prochain la
veille de la présentation du projet en
conseil des ministres dans le détail la
réforme du code du travail prévoit 36
mesure pour le renforcement du dialogue
social selon le nom officiel avec
notamment le plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homale la fusion des différentes
instances représentatives du personnel
ou encore la possibilité de mise en
place de contrats de chantier c'est
aussi enfin et surtout plus de
négociations possibles au coeur des plus
petites entreprises
les accords des accords de branche et
accor disons que quelques nationaux
seront balayés pour des accords
d'entreprise
malheureusement malheureusement dans mon
co entreprise j'ai beaucoup moins de la
pâte syndicats ou inexistants et bien là
ce sera la loi du voile a selon le
calendrier souhaité par le gouvernement
les ordonnances devrait rentrer en
vigueur dès le 25 septembre prochain
l'autre grande actualité du jour c'est
les suites de la catastrophe
irma le président de la république
emmanuel macron s'est rendu aujourd'hui
aux antilles pour constater les dégâts
causés par l'ouragan il a pu ainsi
mesurer la colère des habitants sur
place colère qui se fait grandissante
également en france pour dénoncer la
gestion de la catastrophe c'est le cas
par exemple de florence se choquer une
avocate yvelinoise ses deux fils étaient
présents à saint martin ils sont restés
cinq jours bloqués coincé dans la partie
à néerlandaise de l'île qu'ils avaient
rejoint pour se protéger témoignages
collectés par un nicolas kirillovitch
dès lors qu'ils étaient en zone
hollandaise la cellule de crise
française indiqué qu'il ne pouvait rien
faire pour eux parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas sur la partie française de l'île
et tout d'un coup apparaît c'est une
notion de frontière qui habituellement
n'existe pas sur l'île donc les français
ne voulaient pas s'occuper d'eux est
d'aller les chercher pour les rapatrier
pour les mettre dans des centres
d'hébergement pour les aider leur
trouver de la nourriture
et à boire et les hollandais leur disant
nous on ne vous prend pas en charge car
vous êtes français donc on s'est
retrouvé dans un casse tête
impressionnant sur ce petit confetti
avec une négation totale de la notion
d'europe me semble-t-il
mes enfants ont eu la chance qu'on se
soit des menées auprès du quai d'orsay
grâce à mon député qui est vice
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères qui a pu faire remonter le
problème ce casse-tête impressionnant
aux autorités aux plus hautes autorités
et mes enfants ont pu être évacués dans
un avion militaire dimanche dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi pour être rapatrié à
la martinique et pour venir en aide aux
populations sinistrées du dévastateur
ouragans et irma et les yvelinois
s'organise opérations de sauvetage et de
solidarité on en parle avec notre invité
jean-luc guislain bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le président de l'unité locale de
la croix rouge de saint quentin en
yvelines je précise également que
normalement nous devrions avoir aussi
sur ce plateau le capitaine sébastien
avenel chef du centre d'incendié et de
secours de chanteloup les vignes pour
parler avec lui des pompiers il yn
yvelinois qui sont envoyées en ce moment
aux antilles première question pour vous
jean-luc guislain voilà landes une
catastrophe de ce type qu'elle est là
quelles sont les missions de la croix
rouge
l'émission de la croix rouge sont
d'essayer de venir au secours des
populations le plus rapidement possible
nous avons nous sur place une cellule
spécifique aux amériques caraïbes qui
avait déjà des stocks et qui a pu mettre
en place un certain nombre de choses
à samedi on avait une centaine de
volontaires croix rouge qui élevait été
envoyés sur place qui était arrivé sur
place pour aider avec des kits hygiène
avec des des kits logement d'aidé des
kits peuvent essayer de trouver de l'eau
potable autant que faire se peut plus
des stocks d'eau potable de nourriture
et de vêtements à mais bien sûr ils la
catastrophe d'une telle ampleur que
c'est un peu je peux dire une goutte
d'eau mais c'est pas forcément très
visible visible au total mais bon c'est
ce qu'on était en mesure de faire tout
de suite bon cellule place toute l'année
de toute façon il ya une semaine j'avais
alors mais évidemment la cellule et en
martinique en guadeloupe
au fond peu importe en tout cas pas papa
lé là où la catastrophe s'est produite
martin et saint marin voilà il le
problème d'arrivée à saint martin et
saint barthélémy c'était le même
problème que tout le monde sait qui
aviez pas transport et y est pas de
possibilité d'envoyer un avion
il faut des heures et des heures des
consultations se sont interrompus la
communication était difficile donc mon
nous avons mis en place aussitôt que
faire se pouvait aussi une cellule
d'aidé psychologique pour essayer
d'accompagner les impliquer qu'on a pu
trouver sur place et qu'on a pu
contacter
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons été amenés à faire un appel à
dons parce que on sait que ça va être un
travail de longue haleine et que ça va
demander et du temps et de l'argent pour
arriver à tout mettre en place
c'est d'ailleurs pour faire un don à
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet de la croix rouge française
alors vous disiez tout à l'heure
jean église saint louis qu'il ya des
bénévoles qui sont proposés pour aller
prêter main forte sur place est ce que
c'est le cas par exemple pour les
bénévoles de l'unité locale de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors pas de pas pour aller sur place
nous ont des bénévoles de saint quentin
en yvelines qui sont allés au ministère
des affaires étrangères pour répondre au
téléphone toutes les pour toutes les
recherches de personnes et tout ça donc
mais les gens qui sont partis parti pour
deux jours et on avait pas de bénévoles
sur le moment qu'ils pouvaient se
libérer pour aussi longtemps
mais bon on en avait une centaine de
personnes déjà au niveau national donc
on va voir ensuite pour prendre la
relève
volet solidarité également volets
sauvetage avec notre invité qui nous a
rejoint le capitaine sébastien avenel
vous êtes le chef du centre d'incendié
et de secours de chanteloup les vignes
alors il nous reste très peu de temps
dans cet entretien on va aller
directement à l'essentiel treize
pompiers blinois qui ont été envoyés
pour pour cette catastrophe irma aux
antilles ça fait vingt treize pompiers
donc des yvelines qui sont partis dans
un détachement de 60 personnes
d'ile-de-france en fait donc de chez
nous il ya treize pompiers avec
différentes compétences des compétences
en sauvetage/déblaiement en
reconnaissance en milieu de en de grande
hauteur et puis et puis des compétences
logistiques également une brigade
également cynophile je croise un chien
dans lesquels producteurs cynotechnique
et qui est partie également
donc depuis mercredi dernier tout à fait
et quelles vont être les missions sur
place
du coup l'émission sur place sont de la
distribution de vivres dans un premier
temps et puis après c'est de rétablir
les axes de circulation qui sont des
priorités et puis de faire du bâchage de
renforcement de structures aussi et en
même temps d'installer un camp de base
pour que nos personnels puissent aussi
s'installer et avoir un minimum
d'hygiène pour que la mission puisse
s'installer dans le temps donc le 13
pompiers ils voulaient nous envoyer
c'est une mission qui va durer combien
de temps là bas sur la nôtre est pompier
sont engagés sur une durée de 15 jours
et nous sommes en train de danty sip et
la relève pour que des gens puissent
continuer sur place sur un format
équivalent sur une relève là qui dura 21
jours qui devrait arriver la semaine
prochaine sur un pareil un format de
douze à treize personnes environ qui
viendront donc compléter le travail
continue et parce que effectivement
beaucoup de travail comme vous le savez
sur place donc pas d'effectifs
supplémentaires une relève qui est
assurée exactement voilà une relève qui
vient qui vient à la suite et qui
continue les mêmes missions qui sont
forcément qui s'inscrivent dans le temps
on est derrière chose de ce court
entretien oui c'est aussi l'une des
missions des pompiers d'intervenir là
ils sont affectés dans les yvelines mais
d'intervenir dans d'autres lieux quand
cela est nécessaire
tout à fait on est depuis très peu de
temps une certification internationale
qui nous a permis sur la zone ile de
france donc les quatre départements de
la grande couronne et les paris d'avoir
une capacité d'intervenir toute l'année
en tout temps avec un dispositif d'une
soixante soixantaine de personnes de la
zone ile de france en tous lieux du
globe une fois qu'une demande
internationale et formules et donc on a
cette capacité là aussi à venir en
renfort à l'international ou comme c'est
le cas ici sur des des îles françaises
merci capitaine sébastien hamel chef du
centre d'incendié et de secours de
chanteloup-les-vignes merci également à
jean luc guislain président de l'unité
locale de la croix rouge saint quentin
en yvelines je rappelle d'ailleurs que
vous pouvez faire un site sur un site un
don par don sur le site de la croix
rouge on va y arriver
le site de la croix rouge 3-1 rouge.fr
pour venir en aide aux sinistrés de
l'ouragan et remet à quelque chose de
et j'ai après cette actualité lourdes le
parc jean carillon des clayes-sous-bois
s'est offert une seconde jeunesse
une nouvelle piste de bmx a été inauguré
ce week-end elle fait le bonheur des
petits comme des plus grands découverte
avec mélanie poquet et camille lambert
[Applaudissements]
la pluie n'aura pas découragé les
enfants venus inaugurer la nouvelle
piste de bmx des clayes-sous-bois un
équipement attendu depuis longtemps par
les habitants et virages et revient à ya
ya ya ya ya un conflit sont les grands
lignes pis pour les plus qui ils ont
commencé le bmx ya trois ans et puis il
attendait depuis deux ans d'avoir une
piste où il puisse avoir un entraînement
plus régulier sa rénovation s'inscrit
dans le réaménagement du parc jean car
ils y ont débuté en avril 2017
coût des travaux 1 million d'euros
financé par les clayes-sous-bois et la
région ile de france
un investissement nécessaire pour la
commune on a une vie qui est très
sportive où on a une section lui sm5 est
très investie multisports qui est très
investi et on s'aperçoit qu'on a de plus
en plus de sportifs d'autant plus qu'il
ya certains vont courir ou faire du vélo
dans la forêt était juste à côté
donc voilà on l'a on veut conserver
justement ce dynamisme et c'était un
esprit la piste de bmx homologué au
niveau régional servira aussi aux
entraînements nationaux notamment aux
champions et vice champions de la
section des clayes-sous-bois autre
inauguration du côté de saint cyr
l'école plus de 300 élèves ont fait leur
rentrée dans un tout nouvel
établissement
le groupe scolaire jacqueline de romilly
situé dans le nouveau quartier renard a
accueilli ses premières classes la
semaine dernière camille lambert 16
salles de classe deux cours de
récréation et une bibliothèque
le nouveau groupe scolaire de saint cyr
l'école a fait sa première rentrée en
même temps que les élèves
cette école en travaux depuis un an et
demi marque une étape importante une
nouveau quartier charles renard en
chantier depuis 2008
c'est un peu là une des première
inauguration phare puisqu'on a livré des
premiers logements on a déjà travaillé
sur des mises en état des soldes et des
préparations terrain mais vraiment là
raison des espaces publics et des
équipements publics c'est vraiment l'axé
incarne la vie du projet est le vrai
démarrage et que les habitants peuvent
voir comment comment ce quartier prend
vie la construction de l'école
jacqueline de romilly financé par grand
paris aménagement a coûté plus de 11
millions d'euros
le bâtiment a été pensé de manière
moderne et épuré c'est sur l'écriture
donc c'est l'apprentissage de l'écriture
donc d'où cette façade de cette façade
composée de lettres et après à
l'intérieur une simplicité lecture du
matériau qui permet de voilà de de l'irl
architecture de façon simple et efficace
elle s'intègre parfaitement dans cet
environnement on ne pouvait pas comme
dans d'autres bâtiments de la ville
construira la mansart il était
indispensable de se projeter dans le 21e
siècle et je crois que l'architecturé
extérieure et si près tout à fait plus
de 300 élèves de maternelle et de
primaire sont scolarisés depuis le 4
septembre à terme l'établissement
devrait en accueillir plus de 400
il est un lieu de création et de
diffusion pour l'insertion de
travailleurs en situation de handicap
psychique le théâtre eurydice de plaisir
a lancé cette année son pôle art et
handicap lancement officiel qui a été le
8 septembre dernier objectif faciliter
l'accès à la création culturelle des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine pour
en parler richard leteurtre bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur du
théâtre
eurydice de plaisir alors ce pôle a été
lancé tout récemment on l'a dit une
lancement officiel le 8 septembre
pourquoi le mettre en place je crois que
vous avez fait un état des lieux à la
base
voilà qu'elle est quel était votre
constat d'abord le théâtre uhry 10 et un
esat établissement et service d'aidé par
le travail on appelait ça les ca t1 dans
le temps donc il ya soixante quatre
travailleurs en situation de handicap
qui travaille avec des professionnels
autour et donc tous à travailler autour
des métiers du spectacle où la plupart
en tout cas pour les métiers du
spectacle
et effectivement on est très intéressée
par la question de la culture puisqu'on
est un théâtre autour de la culture
enfin un esat autour de la culture on
est un peu les deux sur ce territoire de
50 à maintenant donc le polar et
handicap et aînés du festival orphée
festival orphée existe depuis 15 ans sur
le territoire des civils annuel voilà
donc art et handicap a réussi 13 as des
spectacles de ceux des personnes en
situation de handicap sur scène et donc
on a fait aussi le constat que une fois
par an d'accord il y avait le festival
et qu'est ce qui se passe le reste du
temps ils vont constater on a donc
procédé à une étude avec des étudiants
en ingénierie sociale qu' il n'y avait
absolument très peu de contacts entre
des établissements médico-sociaux donc
là où les gens habitent ou travaillent
en tout cas sont référencés et puis les
établissements culturels
par contre il y avait un désir des uns
et des autres de travailler ensemble
donc on voit ce désir existait il
existait alors dans d'autres
départements dans le 95 par exemple ça
existe depuis quelques années où
effectivement une compagnie un ami
travaille là dessus et a donc aussi
développer le pôle art et handicap pour
leur territoire et on a décidé de se
réunir et de lancer il ya eu un appel à
projets que par le sénat la caisse
nationale autonomie solidarité qui a été
remporté et donc on a décidé de créer un
pôle art et handicap régionales ça le
but à la fin c'est qu'il ya une
structure régionale avec des antennes
départementales ans en parallèle des
festivals que nous avons aussi réunis
ensemble
donc c'est une dynamique régionale une
dynamique de coopération et le polar et
handicap 78,92 le théâtre eurydice s'en
est chargé et donc effectivement on a
fait un lancement officiel mais on ça
fait trois quatre mois qu'on y travaille
et donc
voilà il ya toute une méthodologie pour
arriver à ça l'idée finale effectivement
et de permettre à tous les
établissements à toutes les personnes en
situation de handicap dans les
établissements médico-sociaux de pouvoir
avoir accès à la culture auprès des
théâtres de proximité parce que l'idée
c'est de travailler et de et de faire
jouer cette proximité là des fois c'est
en face on traverse pas la rue vraiment
un rôle d'entremetteur un faire le lien
entre ces établissements médico-sociaux
et aussi les établissements culturels
par les pôles culturels en fait on
essayait on essaie de briser une glace
peut-être qu'elle n'existe pas tant que
ça mais finalement comme les choses ne
se font pas nous on répertorie on a fait
une cartographie voilà google maps sur
ces sites avec plusieurs étapes
on a ça a permis de visualiser que
autour de sept établissements médico
sociaux il y avait un thé à la wii lieu
qui poisse connaissez pas il faut se
connaissent et lina qui font qu'ils ont
fait office déjà de deux partenariats
mais finalement pas autant que ça et
voilà on essaye de les réunir et de leur
proposer des actions st à trop cher
d'avenir voir au spectacle la
présentation de saison
une visite du théâtre et peut-être même
un atelier de pratique artistique parce
que ça ils sont très demandeurs de ça et
ça ça constitue un ensemble de petites
choses qui fait que toute l'année il ya
une relation pérenne qui se noue entre
ces établissements médico-sociaux et
c'était entre de proximité ça permet
aussi aux tables de proximité de d'aller
un peu plus loin dans la question de
l'accessibilité
on parle bien de boucles magnétiques
langue des signes de douala parce que le
handicap c'est pas une seule chose c'est
sur plusieurs types de handicap et c'est
ça aussi qui perd souvent les médiateurs
culturels et j'en étais à parce que
ouais le handicap mais qu'est ce que
c'est les gens fauteuil c'est compliqué
tout ça on essaye de dédramatiser un peu
de dire où c'est pas si compliqué que ça
si on se parle on trouve des solutions
et finalement c'est pour
le meilleur de tout le monde deux
derniers mots très rapide les prochaines
actions du coup qu'est ce qui va être
mis en place autour de ce polar et
handicap les prochaines on continue à
mettre en place les uns va réunir un peu
les uns et les autres et c'est les
signatures de conventions de partenariat
donc on essaye de pérenniser un peu ses
relations là avec des conventions qui
permet d'identifier des partenaires dans
chaque établissement des personnes c'est
important
et puis on écrit cette convention disant
ben voilà cette année on va faire ça à
ça ça et ça et puis à la fin de l'année
on fera un bilan puis nous on sera
présent pour l'art et handicap pour
rappeler sa pour vérifier que les bonnes
personnes sont toujours au bon endroit
sinon dans leur chercher d'autres voies
la faire en sorte d'être un peu l'huile
des rouages de ces partenariats
et puis je me permets voilà le théâtre
eurydice d'un côté c'est le polar et
handicap
de l'autre c'est le théâtre dit c'est sa
programmation puisque effectivement nous
sommes un théâtre sur saint quentin en
yvelines d'un genre un peu particulier
mais voilà nous existons sur son plaisir
merci le shérif charles tertre d'avoir
été avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes
le directeur du théâtre eurydice et a2
plaisir le théâtre eurydice qui a lancé
tout récemment un pôle art et handicap
il nous a accordé une interview
exceptionnelle cette semaine c'est
l'auteur de titeuf mais bien d'autres
choses encore l'auteur de bd à
participer à une rencontre destinée à la
lanterne à rambouillet principe le
public pose des questions et qui répond
en dessin dans la salle des enfants et
des adultes mélanie poker
et voilà le secret de son pseudo est
dévoilé zep le créateur de titeuf
répondait en dessin aux questions du
public à rambouillet pourquoi la
maîtresse a des cheveux bleus pourquoi
nadia ne sortent pas et titeuf ou encore
comment êtres ou ses idées et un côté
comme comme un musicien qui viendraient
improvisé et j'aime bien ce côté
jean-claude le dessin à côté
spectaculaire comme pendant très
longtemps on n'avait pas utilisé parce
que techniquement c'était compliqué de
venir dessiner on dessine petits et les
gens à voir de loin donc on dessinait
sur des paper board
je trouve que l'exercice est assez
marrant ça évite aussi de brouiller
parce que trop bien la tendance à
fonctionner sur des mêmes idées et là on
sait pas je sais pas ce qui m'attend en
asie comme chou l'auteur silence
attentif dès les premiers trait de
feutre mais éclats de rire à la
découverte du dessin dans le public des
petits comme des grands
peut-être pas s'ils ont du coup parce
qu'on a envie de profiter encore de ses
dessins mais super h on en apprend un
peu plus sur lui et surtout qui n'a pas
que titeuf et que c'est un artiste c'est
un peu grâce à lui qu actuellement je
fais des études de bd il est de tout ce
qu'il a fait dans le monde de la bd ça
fait vraiment plaisir de voir quelqu'un
encore aussi motivé c'était très bien et
une drôle et sombre et qu'il dessinait
très bien et je veux en faire mon métier
plus tard
ça fait plaisir de pouvoir voir un
auteur de bd célèbres
une personne qui a beaucoup d'humilité
cette première rencontre dessinée de la
lanterne a rassemblé près de 200
personnes une vingtaine de chanceux est
reparti avec un dessin original et si
vous aussi vous voulez savoir comment
titeuf fait tenir sa mèche voilà la
réponse la ryder cup se tiendra du 28 au
30 septembre 2010 8,7 au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines et pour
promouvoir l'événement la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux a décidé
d'inaugurer samedi dernier un compte à
rebours géant reportage lors du forum
des associations de michael et demi
d'euros et mélanie poker levy 6 mois
sont désormais prévenus la ryder cup la
coupe du monde du golf arrive le 28
septembre 2018 sur les greens du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour sensibiliser le public à cette
manifestation la ville a décidé
d'inaugurer ce samedi 9 septembre un
compte à rebours géant centre sportif
les pyramides
c'est aux portes de voisins et que
j'aimerai que lévis sinois je dirais
profitent de cet événement soit
conscience de l'homme de l'envergure de
l'événement de ce que ça peut apporter
notre territoire
donc c'est vrai que on a souhaité
on allait les associés en ce jour de
forums et puis que ce soit dans gymnase
qui qui voit passer parce que deux cent
mille personnes par an la ryder cup est
le troisième plus grand événement
sportif planétaire plus de 700 millions
de personnes devraient regarder la
compétition devant leur écran de
télévision
à saint quentin en yvelines près de 70
mille supporters seront présents
quotidiennement pendant les trois jours
de compétition
une première historique point golf en
france c'est la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde les meilleurs joueurs
américains contre les meilleurs joueurs
européens dont je pense que simplement
c'est au niveau sportif c'est quelque
chose de très important mais il faut que
toute la population saint-quentinoise
puissent en profiter
à l'heure où ce reportage est diffusé lé
reste exactement 3 180 jours avant le
début de la compétition avant de
refermer ce journal elle ornera la
mi-septembre la caserne des pompiers de
montigny le bretonneux une fresque en
trompe-l'oeil 2 5 mètres sur 2 viendra
décorer la cage d'escalier elle est
réalisée par une vingtaine de personnes
encadrées par la peintre is with
l'oeuvre s'inspire de l'univers des
casernes en 1845 et du thème de la pompe
à bras un travail de recherche a
d'ailleurs été nécessaires pour mener à
bien ce travail est ce qui rend tous les
trompe-l'oeil intéressant c'est le
travail de recherche justement pour
authentifier un petit peu tous les
vêtements tous les bâtiments les pompes
les matériels que que les pompiers
avaient à cette époque là la forme des
maisons enfin chaque chose en fait on
fait une recherche pour
pour que ce soit authentique donc du
coup c'est un grand thème de curiosité
c'est la fin de ce journal replay et
reportages à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]